a fascinating new result from the catrin
collaboration who managed to get a
spectacular limit on the mass of
neutrinos arguably the most important
particles in the universe yet scientists
don't even know how much these ghostly
particles weigh
fail i blame myself so do i physicists
recently got a better view into the
complex science of neutrinos and found
that they're losing weight that's a good
thing but it needs to get even better
in the beginning let's start with the
beginning of the neutrinos which
actually doesn't begin with a neutrino
at all it actually doesn't begin with
anything at all how can i have some more
of nothing you're killing me smalls it
began with the absence of something let
me explain when physicists first
observed the phenomenon known as beta
decay the process by which the atomic
number of an element can change without
its atomic mass number changing this can
happen in a couple of different ways
inside the nucleus a neutron can decay
ejecting a negatively charged electron
and it becomes a proton a proton can
eject a positively charged positron
becoming a neutron
or a proton can absorb a negatively
charged electron becoming a neutron
but in all these interactions no matter
which one beta decay will one way or
another change the element which we're
dealing with it'll change the atomic
number there's loads of different laws
that describe an incredible detail how
these kinds of particles interact
transform carry charge and what their
masses are
their physical properties are incredibly
important and this has been known for
almost a century but it wasn't fully
understood the role that other particles
besides the known neutron in the known
proton and the known electron played it
was in fact conjectured by a missing
ingredient that there had to be a new
particle it seems like it should be easy
to detect a whole new particle after all
there's only 17 fundamental elementary
particles and objects like protons and
neutrons aren't fundamental at all they
can decay they're not elementary but it
turns out it wasn't so easy after all
physics is hard enough to understand
mathematically but it's even harder to
account for all the other deficiencies
in lacunae that are encountered when you
go into a physics lab
on this channel i love to talk about
experiments experiments that reveal the
truth or falsity of different
conjectured theoretical models
by the early 1930s it was clear that
something else was going on in beta
decay
the ejected particle be it an electron
or positron was consistently measured
traveling with a velocity and trajectory
and therefore kinetic energy
that just didn't align with one of the
most closely held concepts in all
physics conservation of momentum this
stump physicist for quite a while until
wolfgang pauly made a revolutionary
realization
if there were some neutral particle that
was also ejected by this decay it would
be able to account for the missing
energy the missing momentum that was
observed it wouldn't have any impact on
the effects of beta decay on the charge
of the nucleus as for why it hadn't been
detected yet paulie posited that it was
a non-interacting particle
one which left barely any trace on the
apparatus or even on the rest of the
world physicists didn't really take it
very seriously and in fact paulie said
he had committed a cardinal sin he had
conjectured something that could never
be measured well he couldn't be more
wrong in 1955 physicist clyde callan and
frederic reinez managed to detect
anti-neutrinos being shot out of a
nuclear reactor suddenly we knew for a
fact that radioactive decay could eject
these non-interacting charged particles
and it would follow that natural cases
of decay lead to natural sources of
neutrinos
thus began a decades-long search
to find neutrinos directly and examine
their properties the more we know about
them the better we'll be able to
describe how they interact both on earth
in nuclear reactors in the sun in other
suns and at the early universe's birth
the big bang the initial conjecture was
that neutrinos were actually massless
in 1957 the nuclear physicist bruno
patacorbo posited that neutrinos may
oscillate between different states
called flavor states
you see there's three different flavors
of neutrinos they correspond to the
so-called leptons the electron neutrino
the muon neutrino and the town neutrino
these new different flavors of neutrino
correspond to the different types of
other actors in the nuclear reactions
being considered for electrons and
positrons it's obviously the electron
neutrino and its anti-particle the
electron anti-neutrino what ponte corvo
predicted was that a neutrino can
actually oscillate between the different
flavors from electron to muon muon to
tau tau to electron etc
this is called flavor oscillation it's
been measured quite often since then and
was instrumental in the awarding of the
nobel prize to kojita and mcdonald the
neutrino flavor oscillation problem not
only solved the mystery of whether or
not neutrinos could have
non-banishing mass but it also solved
the so-called solar neutrino problem the
solar neutrino problem is the failure to
observe the expected number of say
electron neutrinos coming from the
nuclear reaction that takes place in the
sun
those were not detected because these
flavors can oscillate so if they were
originally produced as an electron
neutrino it could oscillate into a tau
neutrino and then if your experiment
could only detect electroneutrinos you'd
fail to observe any neutrinos whatsoever
it was known now that neutrinos had to
have a non-zero mass so this was a great
discovery and it not only solved the
solar neutrino problem but it also
led to a prediction of what's called a
lower limit
now a lower limit says to a scientist
that a given quantity cannot be bigger
than a given value
an upper limit says it must be lower
than a given limit now the combination
of a lower limit and an upper limit
eventually converges on an actual
measured value and that's where we come
to the catering experiment catrion
experiment stands for calstra tritium
neutrino experiment
and it's based at the kit which is in
karlsruhe germany
the catchment experiment is focusing on
examining the trajectories of outgoing
electrons from decaying tritium atoms
tritium is a heavier isotope of ordinary
hydrogen with two neutrons and one
proton when the tritium's nucleons decay
they can discern the precise impact of
the massive neutrinos on the electrons
energy researchers were able to work
towards getting an upper limit on the
mass of the neutrino which combined with
the lower limit from the neutrino
oscillation experiments paves a way
forward not here or here so much right
here now how does catrin work
it actually uses something that sounds
like a wrapper the mac e filter this
detector system takes the jumbled mess
of outgoing electrons emitted from beta
decay and they straighten them out into
an easy to measure relatively slow
moving beam
by making sure that the beta decay
electrons are going in the same
direction they can control for any
unwanted interactions and make do with
measuring just the energy and that's
what the electrostatic filter is for it
screens out the low energy electrons
which would otherwise possibly
contaminate the experimental results we
all know the most famous equation in all
science e equals m c squared that says
that mass and energy are equivalent to
one another it actually comes back to
haunt us in a certain sense we want to
know the rest mass of a neutrino
but at the incredibly high speeds that
neutrinos are ejected from beta decaying
atoms a lot of that rest mass is
actually in the form or converted to
energy
from neutrino oscillation experiments we
know those masses of the neutrinos are
incredibly small or else we would have
detected them by the experiments that
said upper limits so they're traveling
very close to the speed of light it's
very hard to steer or control them
but because the electrons and neutrinos
are so closely linked to the energy
released by the initial decaying atom
the tritium atom if we slow down an
electron and measure its energy near the
end point of the distribution of its
energy spectrum will actually get a
really good approximation for the
maximum rest mass a neutrino could have
and that's what the mac e filter is
there for what about that tritium atom
well tritium is just a fancy name for
hydrogen 3 which is a fairly rare
isotope of hydrogen highly radioactive
one of the neutrons inside of the
tritium atom
releases an electron via beta decay and
becomes helium the electron and neutrino
that get ejected by this process have a
really low end point energy which as
we've just discussed makes them ideal
for measuring the rest mass of neutrinos
across multiple studies the catrin
researchers concluded that they can be
90
certain that the neutrino's rest mass
must be less than 0.8 electron volts
where physicists use the unit of energy
divided by the speed of light squared as
a proxy for their mass an electron volt
is a unit of energy based on how much a
single electron accelerates from rest in
an electric field impressed upon it of
one volt for reference an electron has a
mass of about 511
000 electron volts
yeah a neutrino is almost a million
times less massive than an electron it's
incredibly small it's the lightest of
all the known elementary particles for
the first time we've broken the
so-called one electron volt barrier
using an experiment on earth
this is fascinating because it paves the
way for future laboratory or earthbound
experiments to make more and more
progress now i should note that
cosmologists and astronomers have broken
the one electron volt and left it far
behind for almost a decade now and
upcoming experiments like the simon's
ray the atacama cosmology telescope the
south pole telescope and the simon's
observatory and eventually cmb stage 4
will all constrain or detect neutrino
masses
and so too will our colleagues that work
on optical telescope surveys for
so-called baryon acoustic oscillations
experiments like boss the dark energy
survey des and the euclid satellite can
also detect or constrain the masses of
these mischievous ghost particles
so will neutrinos stop losing weight
stay tuned for the next weigh-in and
don't forget to subscribe to my mailing
list at briankeating.com for fascinating
messages every month about the exciting
world of experimental astrophysics and
particle physics
if you want to learn more about
neutrinos click here for this special
playlist that i made just for you